let's track this from the beginning
starke something pure
something exciting
then
deal was significant
told you okay so far you like it
I'm feeling it
why stop there
this is it
this is the path I started us on
I'll very strength
invites challenged
challenging incites conflict
culture
breathe catastrophe
the thing isn't beautiful because it
lasts
inevitable
what a sweet-ass run it's been
forces of darkness and bye
universe now
welcome back everyone its charlie you
probably saw in the past couple of days
Marvel officially revealed what their
infinity saga box set looks like so
we'll break it down Marvel also just had
their story retreat where they were
breaking Marvel phase five stories
talking about Fantastic Four x-men
Avengers five all the bigger stuff
that's coming up so because it's New
York Comic Con weekend as I'm posting
this video there was a really cool
Fantastic Four Wolverine interview that
I'll include later in this video but of
course I'm doing giveaways for the
Infinity Saga box set I was only able to
score two copies of it because it's a
limited edition they didn't say how many
they're printing but I do actually have
a couple now that I am capable of giving
away to other people so we can actually
do the giveaway now all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave your best Fantastic Four or x-men
theory for Marvel phase 5 on the video
I'll explain more giveaway stuff at the
end of the video but this is basically
what comes with the actual set because
you're paying about five hundred and
fifty dollars to get the entire thing
it's all 23 films and a special bonus
disc with all the special deleted scenes
that nobody has ever seen before the
Kevin Feige was talking about a couple
weeks ago when he released this x-men
spider-man post-credit scene from the
first Iron Man film so the joke right
now that everybody's saying is if you're
already big Marvel fan you probably
bought a lot of the blu-rays already so
you own the movies and you're basically
paying for a five hundred and fifty
dollar bonus disc don't worry when this
actually drops in November I'll post as
many of those special bonus scenes from
that bonus disc as possible you also get
a Matt Ferguson lithograph of the
picture that covers the spines of all
the jackets of the DVDs was actually
pretty cool he's just one of the concept
artists that works on a lot of Marvel
films you get a number two plaque with
all six Avengers signatures on it
because this is limited edition
and you get the letter from Kevin Feige
but here's actually what this letter
reads so I'll just read it here he says
from the first shot and Iron Man to the
final frame and Avengers endgame the
Infinity Saga has had an astonishing
journey that we've taken together with
our talented actors our incredible crew
Stan Lee and all of his amazing
co-creators and artists and of course
you are most passionate fans at the
start of each of our films the Marvel
Studios team gathers to brainstorm ideas
and storylines
that will surprise the audience at every
turn it's a guiding principle for the
studio because those shocking moments
are the reason we all enjoy to go to the
movies
each surprise a character turn a
gripping action sequence an Easter egg
from the comics is designed to build on
the moments that came before it
expanding the storylines of our favorite
characters and making these films fun to
watch over and over again
so from everyone at Marvel Studios a big
thank you to all our fans without you
the MCU would not be possible while we
have much more in store the Infinity
Saga will always be a special set of
films and we hope that you enjoy
watching it again and again thank you
signed Kevin so he talks about
brainstorming and having a bunch of
stuff planned that's coming up they
actually just had their Marvel retreat
for talking about story in Marvel phase
5 that includes Fantastic Four movie the
x-men reboot movie Nova Silver Surfer
Avengers 5 Young Avengers they've
already got their story for spider-man 3
because Tom Hollands said that they
already pitched the story to Sony back
when they were still fighting with
marvel over the character because they
had to start rolling into pre-production
so that they can start
spider-man 3 next fall
because it's New York comic-con week a
lot of comic-book news happening Matthew
Vaughn who has now under the Disney
umbrella with his franchise of films is
pitching another Fantastic Four film to
the Marvel people a lot of big directors
are but this is what he has to say I've
always loved the idea of doing Fantastic
Four as it was originally written I mean
it's one of my favorite comics I
actually think Fantastic Four as a night
piece of Ip is in theory as big as
spider-man you know I think those the
the values of Fantastic Four and
spider-man I think those the reason if
you're a kid you can imagine being part
of the Fantastic Four family and you can
imagine being Peter Parker so yeah I
think fan fall would be the one that
would excite me the most I'd be on board
and my last thing for you introduced
Taron Egerton to the world there are a
lot of fans like myself who think Terran
would make a great Wolverine if we do
end up seeing another Wolverine would
you would you get behind something like
that yeah yeah why not
I mean listen if I would ask for mr.
Jackman's permission and his blessing
because he is the man and and if you if
if I did if I ended up doing another
another x-men and did Wolverine I would
actually I would want whoever I cast I'd
only do it with Hughes blessing so I
don't know if I'm completely sold on the
idea of tarrant Wolverine but I do agree
with what he says about doing Fantastic
Four as it was originally written so
what that means is is that you don't do
it with teenagers you actually do with
adults they're not married yet and you
haven't introduced Doctor Doom yet
because Doctor Doom wasn't introduced
till Fantastic Four number five in July
1962 he wasn't even the first villain
that they faced they crossed over with
spider-man relatively early in his
career when he came along now
technically they are Marvel's first
families so they came first in the
comics before the x-men came so that's
why we're getting a Fantastic Four movie
before we get an x-men reboot movie but
we all saw that scene at the end of
spider-man far from home there were a
lot of theories about what was coming
inside the New Avengers Tower they never
revealed it then we had all that Marvel
Sony fallout so it seemed like it was a
moot point Lego Marvel's just gonna have
to do whatever they want to do with it
if they had some big grand plan for
spider-man but you can still turn it
into the
Baxter building and spider-man can still
get involved with it somehow with more
Easter eggs in spider-man 3 even if they
don't do Fantastic Four until 2022 2023
because think about it this way we're
probably gonna get that movie around the
time they're getting ready to ramp up
for Avengers 5 and part of the reason
for setting the post endgame future in
2023 is that we're probably gonna see
Avengers 5 in the real world in 2023 so
that the timeline actually makes sense
like oh the movies have finally caught
up with real life but the Fantastic Four
already have a lot of story connections
to the Marvel Universe you talk about
the quantum realm the negative zone more
concepts like Galactus Silver Surfer the
stuff that they're teasing in the
spider-man far from home Nick Fury
post-credits scene but in the same way
that the spider-man movies inside the
MCU started at the very beginning of the
spider-man comics I wouldn't be
surprised if they do the exact same
thing with the Fantastic Four albeit
slightly updated for present-day
obviously you have to explain how they
exist in modern society but everybody
post your Fantastic Four and x-men
theories for Marvel phase 5 and what
will happen is is I'll just keep this
big box set Infinity Saga giveaway open
for the next couple of weeks
everybody click here for my Joker movie
review and click here for my new Iron
Man x-men Easter Egg video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight